there are a number of emotions but I
think the overwhelming one for me is
that of relief and relief in particular
for Sharon and her family and that
finally we have brought the person
responsible for Nikki's murder to
Justice
and a large chunk of that success is
down to those advances in forensics that
made this possible just tell us a bit
more about those and how they aided you
in the case yeah so the new forensic
techniques have been absolutely key in
this investigation so I first became the
sio of this investigation in 2016 and it
was at that point where I've worked with
the scientist in this case James Chapman
to try and look at some opportunities to
help us identify who was responsible and
that's been a long process we had some
success in February 2017 where we
identified a profile but at that point
we didn't know who it belonged to so
that's when the investigation started in
a Earnest really to identify who it
belonged to so we had an initial group
of people from the original
investigation there was 212 men and that
we went about taking samples from um and
indeed David Boyd was number 54. so we
went to visit David Boyd in October 4th
of October and took his sample
um and then the third of November we
managed to identify that it was David
Boyd
and tell us a bit about the public
corporation involved in this I
understand that there were samples taken
from within the community as well just
tell us a bit about that how people
reacted responded and assisted yeah the
community and residents in Sunderland
have been outstanding and have been
really really helpful and supportive and
they have played their part in this
investigation we went to see hundreds of
men that live in Sunderland to obtain a
voluntary sample of their DNA and they
gave their DNA and and without that
truth be told we would have struggled in
this investigation because a big part of
this for us has been to show that it
couldn't have been anybody else and to
satisfy ourselves that it was David Boyd
and him alone that murdered Nikki Allen
and having been the senior investigating
officer on this case you would have been
thinking about family and the impact
it's having them throughout all this
time what are your Reflections on that
the fact that we have someone who would
have been fully blunted out now
living her life taken from her family
yeah it's um it's heartbreaking and you
know I've spent time over the years
speaking to Sharon and there's moments
where I can see where she's looking at
me and she's wanting answers but I can't
give her the answers partly because I
couldn't share some of the information
from the investigation
um so it's it's been really hard for
Sharon for David Nikki's dad and the
rest of the family to have to wait for
so long and and when you know we would
go and visit Sharon and try to explain
and give reasons why it's taken so long
that that's been really difficult as
well because you can see and absolutely
understand her frustration and the fact
that she's lost trust in the police